[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: OK,
why don't we begin.
Hi, everybody.
Let's see how many we
got here, most of you.
I'm sure the others will show
up, hopefully, soon enough.
So welcome back.
We have today's lecture 4.
And let's just remember
what we've been doing.
In the last few
lectures, we were
exploring the regular languages,
as described by finite automata
and regular expressions.
We showed how to convert them
back and forth, those two
models, to one another.
And we also showed how to
prove certain languages
are not regular.
Now remember, finite automata
are a very weak model
of computation.
They only have a limited
memory, finite memory.
And they still aren't
able to do certain things
with their finite
memory, but they are--
if you can pair them
with a general purpose
computer, at least the
way we think about it,
is their capabilities are
just extremely limited.
And so we're going, to
over the next few lectures,
explore some more
powerful models.
We started doing that last
time, the context-free grammars.
And as we'll see, there are
certain things that you can do.
Well, I think we saw
that last time as well.
There are some things you can do
with context-free grammars that
you cannot do with
finite automata.
But they still have their
limitations, as we'll see.
So today what we're
going to do, we're
going to continue
that discussion
by looking at the definition of
context-free grammars in a more
formal way.
One of the things that
we do in this course
is develop a practice
with formalism,
so that's going to be
in the spirit of that.
We also are going to look at
their associated languages,
called the
context-free languages.
So they are going to
be the counterpart
for context-free grammars of
what the regular languages are
for the finite automata
regular expressions.
And then we're going to look at
an automaton-based model, which
is the counterpart to the
grammars called the pushdown
automata.
And we'll see that those
are equivalent in power.
And finally-- well,
and as part of that,
we will show how to convert
the context-free grammars
to the pushdown automata.
And that's what we're
going to do today.
So we're going to move
on then and return
to our topic of
context-free grammars
that we began last time.
And just to refresh
your memory, so here
was that example of a
context-free grammar
that we gave last time.
And it has-- the way
we're going to be writing
context-free grammars is using
a bit of a shorthand, which
looks like this.
When you have
multiple rules that
have the same variable
on the left-hand side,
you can combine
them into one line.
So these two rules over here,
S goes to 0S1 and S goes to R,
can be written in one line as
a little bit more compact way,
this is standard, as
S goes to 0S1 or R.
That's the way you
would read this.
This is really two rules
but written on one line.
So as you recall from last
time, a context-free grammar
has terminals,
variables, and rules.
Those are the parts
that we speak of,
as well as one of
the variables being
designated as a
starting variable, which
gets the whole thing going.
So I'll remind you about
how the computation goes.
So the variables
are the symbols that
appear in the left-hand
side of the rules.
The terminals are
the other symbols
that appear in the grammar.
And the-- we take
the grammar, and we
use it to generate strings,
according to a certain system.
And the system is that you start
up by writing down the starting
variable.
And then once you've
written down that variable,
or whatever variables
you have written down,
you're allowed to
substitute them
according to the
rules, the substitution
rules, that are in the grammar.
So you can keep on
replacing the variables
that you have with the
corresponding right-hand sides.
And then you do that
over and over again
until you don't have
any variables left,
only terminal symbols remain.
And at that point, you have
generated a string that's
in the language of the grammar.
So the grammar's
language is going
to be a language over strings
whose alphabet are the terminal
symbols.
So the terminal symbols
in a certain sense
play the same role as
the input alphabet,
say, for the finite automata.
The variables are
internal-working symbols
for the grammar.
The terminals are the symbols of
which the language is written.
We'll make that more
precise in a minute
when I give the
formal definition.
So the result is the
generated string.
And the language of the
grammar is the language
of all generated strings that
you can get using that grammar.
And the important thing is
that we call that language
a context-free language.
So that's like
what we get from--
that's the analogous thing
to the regular languages,
but here we call them
context-free languages,
the things that you can get
from a context-free grammar.
Again, just a quick recap of
that example we did last time.
So you start out by
writing the start variable.
And then I'm going to give
you two views of that,
either in terms of the tree of
substitutions, which we call
the parse tree, or in terms
of the resulting string
as you do the substitutions.
So here is the parse tree,
here is the resulting strings,
here are the substitutions
that you make.
And now we have R coming
from S, and we have 00R11.
And now we have R in turn
becomes an empty string.
And then the string that
we generated is 0011.
That's in the language
of the grammar.
And now if you play
with this a little bit,
you'll see that the
language of the grammar
is all strings that look
like runs of zeros followed
by runs of ones.
So is that clear?
I think we're going to have a--
I think the next slide is
going to have a check-in,
and so hopefully that'll
get us all together
on the same page with this.
Anyway.
So here's our formal
definition anyway.
We have a context-free
grammar is a 4-tuple.
There are four parts to
a context-free grammar.
These are the parts we've
already been discussing,
the variables, the terminal
symbols, the rules.
The rules are always
that they form
a variable followed
with an arrow
to a string of
variables and terminals.
That's the way we
just write that down.
So this is the form of
the rule, and then we
have the special start variable.
And we all wrap that up into
a package, this 4-tuple.
That's what the
context-free grammar is.
Now we have here--
and now, maybe a
little bit overkill,
but let's talk about, formally
speaking, the way the grammar
actually processes
and produces strings.
So we're going to write--
the standard
notation for this is
that if you have two strings
of variables and terminals--
so imagine you have an
intermediate string that
you've generated in
the grammar so far,
which might be like 00S11
from the previous line,
so that's an intermediate
string that is so far what
you've generated, you're
going to say maybe that's u,
and v might be the
next line down.
So that means we're going
to write u arrow v--
and that arrow is--
the word we're going
to use is "yields."
We'll say u yields v if
it can go from u to v just
with one substitution step.
And then we'll write u yields
v in some number of steps--
or actually, we say
u derives v if it
can go to u to v with some
number of substitutions instead
of just one.
And that's used with the yields
arrow with the star above it.
It means "some number of."
Another way of writing
that is you can say,
u goes to v if there are
a bunch of one-step moves
that you can make which
take you from u to v.
And that whole sequence is
called a derivation of v
from u.
That's a sequence
of steps that you
go through doing these
substitutions one by one
to take you from
u to v, according
to the rules of the grammar.
And lastly, if u is
a starting variable,
then we call that sequence
just the derivation of v. It
could be the derivation
from the start variable,
but that's the assumed
if you don't say it's
a derivation from anything.
The derivation of
v in the grammar
is the derivation of v
from the start variable.
It's just the sequence
of substitutions
that you make, kind of what
I think you would expect.
Now, the language of
the grammar is the set
of all strings of
terminal symbols
that you can get from starting
at the starting variable
of the grammar.
And that's called a
context-free language,
as I mentioned before.
So it's a context-free language.
It's the language of the
grammar for some grammar.
So let's have a little check in
here, again, nothing too hard,
nothing to get
worried about anyway.
We're not counting correct here.
So let's just see, I'm going
to give you two things that
look like grammars.
Which of them are
actually grammars?
And let me just pull
that poll up here.
So which of these are
valid grammars here?
Are they both?
Neither?
I mean, you could kind of
make an argument either way
for both of them.
But both of them are a
little-- have their own--
a bit of weirdness
to them in a way
if you study them for a second.
That's pretty much converged.
Share the results.
So, in fact, the
correct answer is b.
And why is only C2--
well, first of all--
well, what's wrong with C1?
The problem with C1
is that the rules
have things besides a single
variable on the left-hand side.
So having a B1 on
the left-hand side
is not legal in a
context-free grammar.
In fact, there are
other kinds of grammars.
There's a kind of grammar called
the context-sensitive grammar.
The term "context-free" means
you can replace the variable
independent of its context
in the intermediate string,
so independent of
what's around it.
But here, this substitution is
going to-- you can replace B,
but it depends on there
being a 1 next to it.
This is called a
context-sensitive grammar,
but it's not the kind of
grammar we're going to be using,
which are only
context-free grammars.
So C1 is out.
That's not a legit
context-free grammar.
C2, the thing that's a
little weird about C2
is if you try to
generate a string in C2,
you'll see that there's no way
to get rid of the variables,
that you're always going to
be stuck with a variable.
Now, that doesn't
violate the definition
of a context-free grammar.
So this is a
context-free grammar,
but it's not going to
be able to generate
any strings of only terminals.
So this is a
context-free grammar
whose language happens
to be the empty language,
but that's totally OK.
So the correct answer here
is B, that only C2 here is
a valid context-free grammar.
Common-- let's just see.
Common question, does a
string u derive itself?
Yes, a string u derives itself.
That's a little bit of a--
little bit of an esoteric
question there for us
right now, but yes.
A string u-- in this
definition here,
u arrow star u is
legit-- is legal.
Maybe it isn't according to the
way I've written it down here,
but it is a legal thing.
It's not going to really
matter for you anyway,
but it is legal.
OK, let's continue.
Let's do another somewhat
interesting example
of a context-free grammar.
This is a grammar
that can generate
arithmetical expressions
involving pluses and times.
So here it is.
It has how many rules?
Well, there are six rules here.
Each line represents two rules.
So E goes to E plus T or T;
T goes to T times F or F;
and F goes to parentheses
E parentheses or a.
And so the variables are
going to be the symbols that
appear on the left-hand
side, E, T, and F.
The terminal symbols,
which are going
to be the symbols
of the language
that you're going to be
generating, is going to be
the plus, the time symbols.
The parentheses are just
terminal symbols here.
So they're not playing any
special role besides that.
And then you have the
a, which is representing
the upper end on which
those operators would
be working if there was actually
an expression you would use.
But they're just symbols from
the perspective of the grammar.
And lastly, the
start variable is
going to be, as
normally appears,
on the upper left-hand
side of the grammar,
in terms of the way
you write it down.
So sometimes, you might specify
a different start variable,
but otherwise-- if
it's not specified,
it's the one in
this corner here.
So let's just see some
examples of using the grammar
to generate a string.
So here is a string in the
language, a plus a times a.
And this example will reveal
some other interesting features
of the grammar, but let's just
see it in operation first.
So, again, I'll try
to write it to you
in both ways in terms of the
parse tree and the resulting
string as you're doing
the substitutions.
So the-- so first
we start with the E,
then we substitute E plus T. And
we see the resulting string's E
plus T. But now as we're doing
additional substitutions,
the resulting
string that you get
is going to evolve accordingly.
And so I hope it comes
across that this tree here
picture on the left
shows you the structure
of the various substitutions,
whereas on the right,
it just shows you
the strings that you
get as a result of
those substitutions.
So now you can generate
this particular string,
which is now in the
language of this grammar.
You can generate all
sorts of other strings
as well, such as parentheses
a plus a parentheses times a
and so on.
And in fact, this might be a
piece of a programming language
that you're trying to describe.
And one application of
context-free grammars
is to describe the syntax
of programming languages.
What are the legal
programs that you can write
in that programming language?
And not only that,
the grammar can
be used to
automatically generate
the part of the compiler for
that programming language,
which will interpret the--
which will interpret
the structure
of the input, the so-called
parser, which will figure out
the meaning of the
input to the compiler
so that the compiler then
can generate the code,
or if it's an interpreter, it
can interpret the resulting
code that you've given it.
But the very first
step in both of those
is to figure out the meaning.
And the meaning is embedded
within the structure
of the parse tree.
Now in the case of this
particular tree, just
to give you some sense of
what meaning I have in mind,
this parse tree, due to the
structure of this grammar,
has the precedents
for times over plus.
So normally when we write
down a plus a times a,
you assume you're going to do
the multiplication before you
do the addition, even
though it appears second.
That's just the way we
tend to write things.
And this grammar has
grouped it that way for you.
It groups the times lower down
in the tree than the plus.
So the times is going to
be done before the plus,
if you imagine doing this in
terms of the way the tree is
guiding you.
So the tree, as you can
see, has a certain amount
of meaning built into it.
Now, we're not actually going
to be using that in this course,
but I just want to describe
that as an illustration of how
this material can get applied.
So here is what I'm saying,
that the tree contains
additional information.
Now, that's also
relevant if you happen
to have a grammar which
might allow multiple parse
trees for the same string.
That can happen.
And this particular grammar
does not allow that,
but you might write
other grammars,
as we'll see in a minute,
that could generate
the same string in multiple ways
with multiple different parse
trees.
Now that might be undesirable
when you have a programming
language because
typically you want
it to be only a single
meaning for your code.
You don't want it to
be ambiguous and have
multiple meanings.
But ambiguity does
occur, and it's not
necessarily something
we're always
going to see as a bad thing.
So I think as I
mentioned last time,
a lot of this subject
originated with linguistics,
and that's where the
terminology comes from, grammar,
and languages, and so on.
The terminology for
the subject really
comes out of linguistics.
In fact, one of the
key players for that
is an emeritus faculty
member at MIT, Noam Chomsky.
He was instrumental in setting
a lot of this stuff up.
But the-- you can
think of grammars
as applying to natural
human languages as well.
So let me give you a
little example as a pop-up.
It's not directly a pop-up--
a check-in, not directly
relevant to the material
I just presented,
but just a curiosity.
If you take the English
sentence "The boy saw the girl
with the mirror," does that--
is there only one
natural interpretation
for that sentence,
or are there perhaps
other natural interpretations
for that sentence?
So let me pose that to
you as another poll here.
And so I ask you to think about
how many different meanings you
might find for a-- reasonable
different meanings--
I mean, you can--
you're going to go wild, you can
think of zillions of meanings.
But I think in terms
of reasonable meanings,
how many meanings might
you get for the sentence?
People are seeing more meanings
than I'm seeing, but that's OK.
So this is a quick-- why don't
we just give this another 10
seconds here.
And then most of you are
in agreement with me.
I can see here
that you are seeing
that there were two meanings.
The two meanings that I see
here for this sentence are,
when you say the boy saw
the girl with the mirror
is, who has the mirror?
Is it the boy seeing the
girl through the mirror,
or is it the girl
that has the mirror
and the boy just
happens to see her?
So two very different meanings
for the same sentence.
And that's in the nature of
English is just the way--
it's an ambiguous
structure there.
And often we resolve
that ambiguity in English
with other information
that we might have.
But typically you don't
want there to be ambiguity
when you have a grammar,
say, describing a programming
language.
So let's continue on that.
So talking a little bit
more about ambiguity,
I promised you an
example where you might
have an ambiguous grammar.
So if you take these two
grammars, G2 and G3, and G2
from the last slide and G3 is
a similar grammar, in fact,
it's the grammar that has
the very same language--
that gives you the
very same language.
So L of G2 equals L of G3.
Both of them are describing
these arithmetical expressions.
But whereas G2 has
a unique parse tree
for every string
that you generate,
G3 can have multiple parse
trees for the same string.
So I'm just going to
illustrate that here.
So here is the same
string that we generated
last time, a plus a times a.
In G3, the parse tree is
actually even simpler here.
So here I'm showing you the--
there's just the
two substituents
that you need to
make starting from E.
And then to get the
string a plus a times a,
it's a simpler
grammar in a sense.
But there's another
parse tree that'll
give you the same
result. And I've
written that down
below here upside down.
So the upper parse tree groups
the times before the plus,
more inside than the plus.
But the lower parse tree doesn't
have that precedence built
into it and can alternatively
interpret the plus
as being of higher
precedence than the times.
And so in that sense,
we have here a grammar
which has two interpretations
for this same string.
And we call that--
whoops, we call
that an ambiguous derivation,
an ambiguously-derived string.
And the grammar itself is
called an ambiguous grammar.
So let us continue on from that.
By the way, I think there's
a question here that came in.
Like, for example, a plus
a, is that ambiguous in G2?
No.
If you try to apply it, you'll
see the way that G2 can produce
a plus a-- a plus a plus a is
going to group the first two
and then the second one--
then the last one.
You can't derive things
in multiple ways.
Addition is associative,
but the grammar doesn't--
it doesn't-- the grammar--
for the grammar,
it's going to have
a prescribed order for the way
things get interpreted there.
So that's ambiguity.
So let's introduce
pushdown automata, which
is going to be our
automata counterpart
for context-free languages.
So the way I'm going to
introduce pushdown automata,
sort of shifting
gears here now, is
by first giving a new
view of finite automata.
Remember before when we
presented a finite automaton,
we gave it in terms of
a state diagram, which
I've shown here in miniature
form on the picture.
We could do that for
pushdown automata,
but the picture tends
to be very complicated.
So I'm going to take a
bit of a higher level
description for
pushdown automata, which
is I'm calling a schematic
view or a schematic diagram.
And there I'm really not
going to be showing you
the individual states, but
I'm going to be showing you
the individual components
of the machine, more
of an abstraction--
from a more abstract
perspective.
And so from that perspective,
a finite automaton
has here what I'm going to
call the "finite control."
So I'm going to be
suppressing the details
of the states in this picture.
I'm going to represent
those states as the control
of the DFA or the NFA.
They're really going to be the
same from this pictorial point
of view.
The input is going to appear
as a string that's written down
on what we're calling a "tape."
Again, this is somewhat of
an anachronistic terminology.
Back in my days, people
actually did feed their inputs
into computers on
a tape sometimes.
We don't do that
so much anymore,
but that terminology
has stuck, and it's
going to be a persisting
later on in the course,
too, so you might as
well get used to it.
So the input is going
to appear on a tape,
or sometimes called
an input tape.
And the way the machine
actually will read that input--
whoops-- it's going
to have a head, which
is going to be starting
at the left side
and moving from left to right,
reading the symbols that appear
on the input tape one by one.
So this is our picture
of a finite automaton,
just redone from last
time, just a different way
of picturing it.
Now, that's going to be setting
the stage for the picture
of a pushdown automaton,
because a pushdown automaton is
like a finite automaton,
but it has an extra feature,
it has an extra
device attached to it.
And that's called a "stack."
So here's the schematic diagram
for a pushdown automaton,
and that's going to
be a stack, which
is going to be basically a
form of auxiliary storage.
Now remember, part
of the limitation
for a finite
automaton was that we
had a limited amount of memory.
So we were not able to do
some very simple things,
like counting, because
we had a limited memory.
So the pushdown
automaton is going
to be able to use its stack
as a kind of unbounded memory,
but a memory that's restricted
in the way it can be used.
So it's unlimited but still
restricted, as we'll see.
So the way the pushdown
automaton uses its extra memory
on what we're calling the
stack or a pushdown stack
is that you can write symbols
instead of only reading
symbols.
But those symbols can
only be read at the very--
written or read at the very
top of this list of symbols.
And every time you add a new
symbol, the other symbols that
are already there get pushed
down, so hence the name.
People also often
refer to it as a stack
of plates in a cafeteria, if
you've ever seen those things,
or you can remember
back to the days
when we went to cafeteria, which
are getting further and further
away.
But even at the cafeteria,
you had a stack of plates.
And as you remove plates from
them, they were on a spring,
and they kept coming up.
Or if you add more,
they would go down.
And it's the same idea.
Imagine these symbols
here are on a spring,
and the more symbols you
add, the more they go down.
Or if you move them, and
read them, and remove them,
then they move back up.
So a pushdown automaton
operates like a finite--
like a non-deterministic
finite automaton, as we'll see.
Pushdown automata
for us are always
going to be allowed to
be non-deterministic.
So we're not going to
be studying the pushdown
automata that are restricted
to be only deterministic.
I'll say more about
that in a second.
But they operate like an NFA,
except they can write or read
symbols from the
top of the stack.
And when they write, they're
adding the symbol on,
pushing down that stack.
And when they're
reading, they're
removing symbols from the
stack, and thereby lifting
up the stack.
We give them special names.
So those of you who have
seen stacks already,
this is, I'm sure,
old hat for you.
But I'm sure not everyone
have seen stacks before.
So the special name for
writing onto a stack
is called a "push
operation," so that you're
pushing a new symbol down
on the top of the stack,
and it pushes everything down.
Whereas when you're
reading a symbol
and removing it from
the top of the stack,
that's called a "pop."
So that's reading and removing.
And we always think of
those as going together.
Writing and adding and reading
and removing are combined.
I mean, you might
wonder, well, can't I
just read it and leave it
alone and not just remove it?
No.
You can get that effect by
reading it, which removes it,
and then putting it back if you
really want it to stay there.
But the way we're
setting it up is
that reading comes
with removing,
writing comes with adding.
Again, they're called
pushing and popping.
So let's do an example.
So we have here a
pushdown automaton
for a language
we'll call D. We've
seen that language before.
It was-- actually, we used
the same letter for it,
strings of zeros
followed by ones,
where the numbers were the
same of the two, 0 to the k 1
to the k.
We couldn't do that
with a finite automaton.
We will be able to do that
with a pushdown automaton.
And here I--
I thought I wrote down
the input here, but OK.
So the basic idea is I'm going
to give you an input now,
and the pushdown
automaton is supposed
to test whether that
input is in the language,
whether it's of this form.
Now it has the ability
to use the stack
because it's going to have to
count how many zeros it has.
And so the way
it's going to do it
is it'll have a bunch of
zeros, hopefully, and then
a bunch of ones,
and you want to see
they are of the same number.
It's going to take the zeros
and store them on the stack
until it sees a one.
And then it's going to
start to read the ones,
and it's going to
remove the zeros,
matching them off one to one
with the ones that it's seeing.
So you initially first read
the zeros and push them
onto the stack until
you read a one,
and then you read the ones while
popping zeros from the stack.
And you enter the accept
state if the stack is empty.
Just like with a
finite automaton,
entering the accept
state only counts when
you're at the end of the input.
So without even me
needing to say anything,
it's really saying you
would enter the accept state
if the stack is empty at
the end of the input string.
But that's implicit because
it only takes effect
at the end of the input string.
If you enter an accept state
alone in the middle somewhere,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't affect anything.
And with that we're going
to take a little break.
And then we will be back shortly
to look at pushdown automata
again in a more--
with a more formal definition.
Let me put that it's
going to be five minutes.
Let me see if I can figure out
how to get my timer screen up
here.
Yes.
And we will-- when the
candle burns down to nothing,
we will return and continue.
OK, our candle has burned
down and has gone out.
I never actually watched and see
what would happened at the end.
So we're good to go.
Let's continue.
Good.
And let me put
myself back in there.
All righty.
So we were doing
pushdown automata.
And we just did that example
of 0 to the k, 1 to the k.
Now that you have
a stack, we can
do all sorts of fancy things
that finite automata could not
do just with their
limited memory.
So let's take a look at how
we define pushdown automata.
So now pushdown automata is
actually going to be a 6-tuple.
So it's a little bit-- got
some fancier stuff here
to deal with, not too
much, but a little bit.
And so it has--
let's look at these a
little bit more carefully
since there's some novelty here.
We have the input alphabet,
just as we had before, sigma,
but we also have gamma,
which is the alphabet
for using the stack.
Now, you might ask, why don't
we just use the same alphabet?
Well, it's really a
matter of convenience
that we would like to be able
to have other symbols that
could include the
input alphabet,
but could include
other things as well.
So it just gives
you more flexibility
in terms of what you're going
to be writing on the stack.
The transition function,
more complicated.
So I think-- I don't know
if I'm going to even say
what the other things are, but
these are the accepting states,
this is the starting state.
So that's the same as before.
But the transition function
is a much different animal
here in a pushdown automaton.
So let's just try to
unpack that and understand
what it's saying.
So the transition
function tells us
how the machine operates, how
it goes from state to state,
how it's going to read
the input, how it reads it
from the stack, and what
am I to write on the stack,
too, because that's going to all
happen under program control.
So what this means
here is that when
the machine is in
a particular state,
reading a particular
input symbol--
let's ignore the empty string
subscript for the moment.
So it's in a particular state
reading a particular input
symbol and with a certain
stack symbol appearing
at the top of the stack.
So that's all information that's
available to the controller
of this pushdown
automaton, the transition
function, the current
state, the next input
symbol, and the symbol
at the top of the stack.
And once we have that, we know
what new state we can go into
and what new symbol we can
write on the top of the stack.
So that's what the right-hand
side of this function
specification means.
So this is where the input
to the function, this
is going to be the output of the
function, state and new symbol
to appear on the stack.
So this is the popping symbol,
this is the pushing symbol.
So now there are
two things that bear
explanation here first of all.
Now this is a power set.
So this is going to be
representing, as we did before,
a non-deterministic machine.
We may have several
possibilities,
and we're going
to represent that
as a set of possibilities
for the machine
that it could go
to at any point.
I will give an example of
how a pushdown automaton uses
its non-determinism in a minute.
The other thing
is these epsilons.
So we have to understand
why they are there.
And we remember we
had them for the NFAs,
corresponding to when the NFA
had an epsilon transition,
the empty transition.
So it could go along
in that transition
without reading any input.
So this is going to
play the same role here.
So if you have--
instead of an input
symbol from sigma
appearing in this part of the--
for the transition
function, instead you
have an epsilon appearing.
That means that the transition--
that move of the machine
can happen without
reading any input symbol,
just like for the NFAs.
Or if you have an epsilon
appearing for the stack symbol,
that means you can make that
transition without reading
any stack symbol.
So whatever is sitting
on the top of the stack,
it doesn't matter, the
machine can make that move.
And it won't read
anything either,
or not going to pop anything.
It's just going to be
proceeding without looking
at the stack at all.
Or it might have both of
them, in which case, it's
going to go from one
state to another state
without looking at the input
or at the top of the stack.
So that's what the
possibility of epsilon
means for the transition
function in those places.
The epsilon appearing
over here means
something a little
different, but very similar.
What that means is that
we won't write anything
on the top of the stack.
That's going to be--
we will go to a new state,
but without doing any writing.
So we'll leave the stack alone.
So here it means we're
not going to read anything
if it's in this position,
and this position
means we're not going
to write anything.
So all of those things
are valid and legal
from the perspective of
constructing a pushdown
automaton.
And I've illustrated here,
just with a little bit
of an example, if you have delta
that applies to some state q,
reading an input
symbol a and popping
a c from the top of the
stack, then you might have,
let's say, in this
case, two possibilities
that you might end up going to.
You might end up going to
states r1 or to state r2.
And in the former case,
you'll end up writing a d,
pushing a d onto the
top of the stack.
And in the latter case,
you would be pushing an e
onto the top of the stack.
So this is I'm trying to help
you look at this notation.
I hope that this
is clear to you.
I'm sure for some of you it's
too slow, but others of you
I'm trying to help along.
But if you're really
struggling with this notation
at this point, you're going
to have to dig in and make
sure you follow it.
It's only going to
get harder from now.
I'm going to stop going
over these kinds of points.
And if you're still
struggling, you can't get it,
this is not the right class
for you, I'll be honest.
So we're just going to
be taking off like--
we're going to start to
accelerate fairly quickly.
So it's a
non-deterministic machine.
We accept, like we did before.
There might be several different
threads of the computation.
You're going to end
up accepting if some
of the threads, at
least one of the threads
ends up in an accept state at
the end of the input string.
That's when the machine
overall accepts.
It's just the way we normally
think of non-determinism.
Again, you can use
the models that we
had before in terms of
guessing or parallelism,
whatever works for you.
And sometimes different
things work in different--
at different occasions.
But that's how
non-determinism works.
We'll do an example of it now.
Here is a pushdown automaton
for a different language
we haven't seen before, I don't
think, well, maybe we have,
which is going to be
using it's non-determinism
in an essential way.
This is a language
where non-determinism
is going to be critical.
Without it, you can't--
a deterministic pushdown
automaton, which is something,
by the way, that people study.
And there's a section
of my book about that,
it's section 2.4, because it
has relevance to applications.
We're not going to address
that in this course.
So you can just
skip section 2.4.
It's pretty technical,
I'll have to say, but still
quite interesting and beautiful
if you like that stuff.
But it's technical.
We won't do it.
So here is this input string
ww reverse for all possible w's
over our alphabet 0, 1.
And what w reversed, by the way,
means is writing w backwards.
So this is all strings
followed by a reversal
of the same string, the
string written backwards.
Really you can
think of these as--
well, so these
are strings that--
well, here's an example, 0,
1, 1, 1, 1, 0, the string
written backwards.
So this is a string in the
language appearing on a tape
as I described.
So how is the machine going
to recognize this line, which
is going to be somewhat
similar to before, but with one
important difference.
And if you imagine--
and I like to use this
kind of anthropomorphizing
these things, putting yourself
in the place of the machine,
and thinking how
you would do it.
So if you imagine getting these
symbols one by one, 0, 1, 1,
you don't know
what's coming next
as you're getting the symbols.
You have to figure
out how to match off
the second half
with the first half.
So you're going to put the
first half on the stack,
and then you're going
to remove the first half
and match it off
with the second half.
Conveniently, the first
half comes out backwards.
The stack is a first in
last out kind of thing.
So it comes out
in reverse order.
So that's perfect for matching
off with the second half.
But the tricky part
with this language
is, how do you know when
you're at the middle
because you don't
get to see the rest.
You only get to see
what you've seen so far.
You don't know what's coming.
So when you read that second
one-- well, at this point,
you're reading 0, 1, 1, now
you're reading that second one,
you don't know that
perhaps it's just
going to be a 0 following
that and it's going to be all.
So maybe you should be deciding
so that this point here
that I've marked
is the midpoint.
And you put 0, 1 on
the tape and then
start popping the second
one and matching it off
with the first one.
That would be a tempting thing
to do, but you just don't know.
And that's where
the non-determinism
is going to be essential.
So let me write
down more of this.
So what you're going
to do is you're
going to read and
push input symbols,
but non-deterministically
guessing
that you're at the middle.
So you're going to
non-deterministically
either repeat that and continue
to read and push symbols
onto the stack, or
you're going to go
to 2 deciding that, or guessing
that you're at the midpoint,
and now it's time to start
reading and popping instead
of reading and pushing.
So you're going to
read input symbols
and popping the stack
symbols, comparing
the two, the symbols that
you're reading at the top,
the symbols you're
removing from the stack.
If they ever disagree, then this
thread of the non-determinism
rejects because either the
input is not in the language
or at least you have
made a wrong choice
as to where the midpoint is.
And then you're going to
enter the accept state
if the stack is empty.
And ignore this part for
the moment, this software
reference.
Let's just-- I'll speak
to that in a second.
But I just want to
make sure we understand
that at an intuitive level
how this machine is using
it's non-determinism
to recognize
this language because the
non-determinism is critical.
And it's important
that you understand it.
So let me just make
some side comments,
and then we'll come back
to this software remark.
So first of all, one question
that comes up a lot--
well, I'm not paying attention
to the chat here, sorry.
So if you're not getting
an answer from me,
you try the TAs.
But one of the--
one of the questions
that comes up
a lot when they're thinking
about non-determinism
for pushdown automata is,
what happens to the stack?
The stack gets replicated in
the non-determinism every time
the machine forks, just
like everything else
gets replicated.
So an entire--
every time there's
a fork in the non-determinism
and the machine branches
into multiple possibilities,
the entire machine
replicates the current
state, the current position
of the head, the stack
and its contents.
All of that gets replicated.
And the two sides of the-- the
two branches or the two sides
of the fork each
go on independently
in their merry way, doing
their own thing independently.
And then if any one
of them accepts,
that's the only way they sort
of-- a kind of a communication
because the one that
accepts raises the flag,
and then the overall
machine is set to accept.
So the non-determinism
forks replicate the stack.
[INAUDIBLE] saying it.
I just want to make
sure you got that.
And then this language
requires non-determinism,
that I said earlier, so our
PDA, pushdown automaton model is
going to be non-deterministic.
I mean, you might have examples
which are deterministic,
but the model is going to
always allow non-determinism.
What's this bit
about the software?
So if you look at this
formal definition here,
it doesn't have anywhere
in it the ability
to test if the stack is empty.
That's not part of the
hardware specification,
at least as we are describing
it for a pushdown automaton.
You can might imagine somebody
else describes pushdown
automata in some other way
which gives that as a primitive,
but we're not going to do that.
Why?
Because we don't need
a primitive for that.
You can get the
effect of testing
if there's an empty stack,
even if you don't have that
as a primitive for the machine
because what you can do
is you can start the
machine off when it--
and the very first thing it does
is it writes a special symbol
to mark the bottom--
what's going to eventually
be the bottom of the stack.
There's going to be some special
symbol, maybe a dollar sign
symbol.
That's the very first
thing the machine does.
And then it proceeds as before.
And if it ever sees that
dollar sign symbol again,
it knows the stack
is effectively empty.
So you can get the
effect of testing
for the static being
empty, even if you don't
have a primitive for that.
And we're not going to actually
fuss about details like that.
So you can use-- when you're
writing your homework sets,
you can just use the
assumption that you
can test for an
empty stack, which
is what I'm going to do myself.
So let's continue on.
Yeah.
So now what we're going to do,
we're going to prove our one--
so far we really
haven't proved anything,
we've just given some
definitions and some examples.
Today was going to-- now
we're going to come to our big
theorem, which actually is
important and has some meat
to it, and that is,
how do we convert--
I claim that context-free
grammars and pushdown
automata are equivalent.
Well, we're going to prove that
equivalence in one direction,
converting the grammars
to pushdown automata.
So let me show
you how that goes.
In some ways-- and
it's a nice proof,
not super complicated, but
it has some meat to it.
So if I give you a
grammar here, what
I'm going to tell you how to
do is convert that grammar
into pushdown automaton,
which does the same language.
So if you were checked
out for a minute,
please come back because
we're starting this topic now,
that you can think about
this as a good re-entry
point if you've been doing
something else, which
I can't tell, a good thing.
So converting a given grammar
to a pushdown automaton,
how is that going to work?
So the idea is--
OK-- actually, before
I tell you the idea,
let's just think
about it together.
Again, I like to think about
the pushdown automaton,
building a pushdown automaton
the way you would do it.
So a grammar is a
generation device.
It generates strings.
A pushdown automaton-- or
thinking about it as you,
you are recognizing it.
You are given an input,
and you want to know,
is it in the language?
So you want to know, is it
possible for that grammar
to generate that
input you're given?
So how are you going--
how are you going to do that?
And how are you going
to test if the input is
in the language of the grammar?
Well, the thing that
you would naturally do
is you'd say, well, can I
derive that string using
the rules of the grammar?
Let me start with
the start string
and try to do
substitutions and see
if I get the string I'm given.
And if I can get it, then I
know it's in the language.
That's a natural thing to do.
You're just going to try
to do the substitution see
if you can get to the string.
Now the thing is, there might
be many different substitutions
that you could make.
And that seems like a really
challenging, hard thing
to figure out which
substitutions to use
among the many possibilities.
That's where
non-determinism is going
to come in because you can
think of yourself as guessing
which substitutions to make.
And you're always going
to make the right guess.
So the choices of which
substitutions to make,
that's not going to
be a problem for you.
That's going to be managed
by the non-determinism.
So imagine you're always going
to make the right substitution,
but now the challenge
is, how do you
keep track of the
intermediate results
as you're doing
those substitutions?
And that's where the
stack is going to come in.
The machine is going to write
down those intermediate results
on the stack.
But even there,
there's a subtlety.
That's an important subtlety
that you have to look at.
So let's try pulling
that together
so far before I get
to that subtlety.
So as I mentioned,
the pushdown automaton
is going to start out
with a starting variable
and is going to be guessing
the substitutions to make.
It's going to keep the
intermediate results
on the stack.
When it's done doing
all the substitutions
and it has only terminal
strings on the stack,
it can compare with
the input and see
if it got the right thing, so if
it made all the right guesses.
So you think of it
as guessing, doing
the right guesses,
but in the end
you have to check to make
sure that you got the right--
that you did all
the right things,
and you will accept when
things have matched up,
and you made all
the right guesses.
So in the end, you have
to check that you actually
got that input from doing
those substitutions.
So let's try to see this
operating in action.
And then you'll see the
subtlety, the delicacy,
a problem that's going to arise.
Hopefully you're following,
at least in part,
what I'm saying so far.
So here is the input.
We do know that that's
an input in the language
that-- we've been seeing
this example multiple times.
So here is the input
appearing on the input
tape, a plus a times a.
And now the pushdown
automaton is
supposed to be accepting
that input because it's
in the language of the grammar.
So it's going to operate
by first writing,
to start off, the starting
variable on the stack,
and then doing the substitutions
as we're going along.
So we're going to substitute
E goes to E plus T.
So we do that
first substitution.
And then we do the next
substitution here, the E--
so if you're looking
at this tree here,
this is the right
tree for that input.
So we substitute E
by T. So far so good.
The automaton can make
that substitution.
Then the next substitution
is going to be a little--
so where E plus T,
we substitute here.
We got T plus T. And now we're
going to substitute the T times
F, which is this T over here.
We want to substitute that.
And that appears as T times
as F now on the stack.
Now, if you're
following me, you should
be suddenly getting nervous
because we just cheated.
It's OK doing substitution--
doing these replacements
at the very top of the stack
because the pushdown automaton
has access to the top.
That's how stacks work.
But it does not have access
deep down within this deck.
That is not how--
that is not how stacks work.
So that's cheating.
But ignoring the
cheating for the minute,
if you could replace those--
do those substitutions
deep down within the stack,
this would all work.
We would be good.
You would do the substitutions
one after another
until you ended up
with no variables,
and then you have
the string here,
and you're going to match it off
and compare it with the input.
It's all done in the right
way so that the things are
in the right order so after
all the substitutions,
you'd have a plus a times a
sitting here in the stack,
you compare that with the
input, it's going to match up,
and you'll end up
accepting, all good.
So how do we deal with
that problem here?
The problem, access below
the top of stack is cheating.
What are we going to do instead?
So the idea is
actually pretty simple.
Well, if you understood what
I've said so far, fixing
that is actually not too bad.
Sort of fading out here.
I'll put some more
light on my image.
So how do we do that?
How do we get the
effect of the access
below the top of the stack?
And the way we're
going to do that is
by making the-- what we're going
to do, we're only going to do
substitutions that we can
make at the top of the stack.
So whenever there's a variable
at the top of the stack,
we're going to do
the substitution
because the top we can access.
Now what happens if we have
a terminal symbol sitting
at the top blocking our way
from accessing variables below?
Well, actually,
that's an easy case
to handle because we have
a terminal symbol sitting
at the top, they're never
going to change anyway,
so you might as well match them
with the input at that time.
So when you have a terminal
sitting at the top,
we'll just read another input
symbol and match it off there.
And we just keep reading
the terminal symbols off
until we have a variable
sitting on the top,
then we do a substitution.
And we keep
substituting variables
until we have a terminal,
then we read it,
then we compare
it with the input.
And in so doing, we will end
up getting the same effect
that I described
before without ever
needing to dig down into
the interior of the stack
and doing substitutions there.
They're all going to
rise up to the top.
And we can always
do them at the top.
So anyway, I forgot
to do that here.
So instead, only
substitute variables
when they're at the
top of the stack.
If a terminal's on the top, pop
it and compare with the input,
reject it if they're not equal.
So if you ever have
something which is not
matching the way
it's supposed to,
I mean, that thread's
just going to fail.
Then there was not a-- a bad
non-deterministic choice was
made, or maybe the input was
not in the language anyway,
and there were no good choices.
So my animation broke here, so
let me just put the whole thing
up in front of you.
So here is the
actual construction.
Push the start
symbol on the stack.
If the top of the
stack is a variable,
replace it with a
corresponding right-hand side,
doing a non-deterministic
choice among
the various possibilities.
If it's a terminal,
you pop it and match it
with the next input symbol.
And if the stack is
empty, you accept.
So here is how the
stack would actually
look for this particular input.
It would start off the same.
You'd have E, and then
substitute with E plus T.
And then we're
going to always do
the substitutions at the top.
So E gets substituted by F
Is that right?
No.
This slide I messed up.
I apologize.
So E gets substituted by T,
which gets substituted by F.
And the point is
that when you get
to an A sitting at the top--
forgive the typos here, now
we have a terminal symbol,
and that's going to get matched
off with the next input symbol
and get removed.
And now we have just
the plus and the T left.
And then the plus is
also a terminal symbol.
That's going to get matched
off with the next thing.
We just have a T
sitting on the top,
and now we can do
a substitution.
So that's how it works.
That's all I wanted
to say, I think.
Oh, yeah, there's
one just remark.
So we're not going
to prove this,
but I do need to say
this, that actually you
can do the conversion in
the other direction, too.
You can convert a--
so a is a context-free
language if and only
if some pushdown
automaton recognizes a.
And if you haven't seen if and
only if, it's an expression
I'm going to use,
again, over and over.
So you should get used to it.
It stands for "if and
only if," and which just
means the implication
goes both ways.
So "a is a
context-free language"
implies that some pushdown
automaton recognizes
a and vice versa.
So there's really two things
you need to prove whenever
you have an if and only if.
You have to prove
both directions.
So thinking about it that
way, splitting them in half,
the forward direction
we've already proved,
converting a pushdown--
a context-free grammar
to a pushdown automaton.
The reverse direction
we're not going to prove.
It's in the book
if you're curious,
and you are responsible
knowing that the fact is true,
but you don't have to know the
proof, which is a somewhat--
a little bit complicated.
And I think it would take us
too long to go through it,
so you're not
responsible for it.
So there's a last
check in here that I
have for you, which is
just a question, which
you can answer based
on the material
that we presented so far.
Is every regular language
also a context-free language?
Just "yes," "no,"
or you're not sure.
So let me launch
that as a poll here.
OK, about to close.
A new polling, and
sharing results.
This one, I think,
you pretty much--
most of you got.
Some of you are not sure.
Every language is in fact
a context-free language.
And the way to see that is
that every regular language
can be done by a DFA or an
NFA, as we already showed.
And a DFA or an NFA is really
just a pushdown automaton
that never uses its stack.
So you can always think of a
DFA as a pushdown automaton.
And we already argue that
pushdown automata are
equivalent to
context-free grammars,
and so they do the
context-free languages.
So anything that you
can do with a DFA
you can also do with
a pushdown automaton,
and so therefore all the
regular languages are also
context-free languages.
So with that, let's just
pull things together,
a little quick recap
as to what we've
been doing so far in the class.
We have the regular languages
and the context-free languages.
We had the two forms
of getting at them,
the recognizer form, which
is like the automata-based
perspective, like
either a DFA or an NFA
in the case of the regular
languages, the pushdown
automaton for the
context-free languages.
And for the generators, we
had the regular expression
for the regular languages and
the context-free grammars--
for the context-free languages.
And as we just pointed
out in our last check-in,
the regular languages form
a subset and, in fact,
a proper subset of the
context-free languages,
as shown in this Venn diagram
because we have already
exhibited languages that are
context-free but not regular.
So a quick review.
We've defined the
context-free grammars
and their associated languages,
the context-free languages;
we defined pushdown
automata; and we
showed how to convert
context-free grammars
to pushdown automata.
And that's all I
have for you today.
But here's a question
I'll answer to everybody.
Why do we restrict
ourselves to a stack?
Why don't we use
random access memory?
We will use random access
memory for the next model,
called a Turing machine.
And we're going to introduce
that I think the next lecture.
So that's going to be
the model that we're
going to stick with
throughout the term.
But we have not--
we were introducing weaker
models as a kind of prelude
to the more general-purpose
computational model really
to get ourselves warmed up and
also because, for the weaker
models, you can fully analyze
them in a way that you cannot
for Turing machines.
As you will see, you
can determine properties
of languages for the weaker
models that you cannot
for the more general models.
And so I think that's helpful
to have that perspective,
that for some cases, you
can get a full analysis,
in some other cases you cannot.
But anyway, that's the
reason why we restrict it
to the stack, besides the
fact that these models have
applications that I think
are worth people seeing.
Why-- yeah, for some
reason we chose a stack?
Well, why did we
choose a stack and not
some other data structure
for our temporary--
for our extra storage?
And the reason for a stack,
for one thing, the stack
is exactly what you need to
get you the correspondence
with context-free grammars.
If we used some other
storage, like a queue,
for example, instead
of a stack, in fact,
you get a very
different outcome.
And it's an actually interesting
exercise to see what happens.
What do you get if you use a
queue as an external storage
instead of as a stack?
It's a good homework problem.
Maybe I'll assign it.
Let's see.
And if a--
OK.
We showed-- so we showed
that non-determinism can be
eliminated for finite automata.
So NFAs and DFAs are equivalent.
What about for
pushdown automata?
The answer is no,
they're not equivalent.
I think I mentioned
that earlier,
but I don't mind repeating it.
There are certain languages
that can be done only with
non-deterministic pushdown
automata and cannot be done
with deterministic
pushdown automata,
for example that language
ww reverse that requires
the non-determinism in order for
the machine to be able to guess
where the middle is.
So, OK, I'm going to head off.
Thank you, guys, and
see you on Tuesday.